what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and the Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
trailer just dropped and it was awesome
and there is a lot to talk about with
this trailer I'm going to explain some
things that you absolutely must know in
order to understand what exactly is
happening in this trailer I also have a
theory on what I think a huge plot point
is going to be in this film that they're
kind of alluding to in this trailer so
let's go ahead and Dive Right In but if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU videos now the trailer
starts off with Peter Quill's voice
saying that they've been gone for a
while we see Star-Lord and we see that
they have new Guardians of the Galaxy
outfits and these outfits are actually
really in line with some of their comic
book counterparts specifically from the
annihilation storyline the Legacy
storyline Realm of the Kings and many
many more and the suits do look pretty
dang good now you've probably noticed
that the Guardians of the Galaxy are now
in a new mship they are no longer in the
Benetar when the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special came out we saw mantis
and Drex use this ship but we didn't
know if this was going to be for good it
looks like it is for good James Gunn the
director of the film actually explained
that the Benetar is still there however
it is much smaller so it looks like they
just simply upgraded to a larger ship
here now Star-Lord says that the
Guardians have been gone for a while but
no matter what happens next the Galaxy
still needs its Guardians now him saying
that they've been gone for a while most
likely is in reference to the snap
remember over half the guardian's team
got snapped or if you're a Gamora you
got directly killed by Thanos himself so
they were gone for that five-year time
span where everybody was snapped with
the exception of rocket and nebula so
now they're back also keep in mind this
does take place after the events of Thor
love and thunder so they've been back
for a little bit now but it's most
likely that they're going to address
some things that happened immediately
after Avengers in-game 4 will probably
be in this movie just a little bit even
if they only just showed them dropping
him off and go in their separate ways
and go into all the different distress
signals across the Galaxy now we've also
learned from the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special that the Guardians
actually bought nowhere so these
uniforms and this new upgraded ship
comes with new territory here they're
trying to look more official because
they are now the owners and leaders of
nowhere they are turning around nowhere
it's not just this big Outlaw City in
the middle of space anymore but the
Guardians are trying to get it in shape
to be a good place where many people can
meet and trade and do good business with
each other we saw Star-Lord handling
stuff like this multiple times
throughout the holiday special but
here's where things get interesting with
the Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer
the new ship and the Guardians land on a
new planet it looks a lot like Earth
however the inhabitants of this planet
that looks exactly like Earth are all
humanoid animals the Guardians walk out
of their ship and say they come in peace
and then a little sweet girl who looks
to be possibly an III maybe a lemur
tries to be nice and offers them her
ball in which Drax immediately picks up
and plays dodgeball and Chucks it right
at her head now this obviously leads
everybody else to believe they do not
come in peace and they start throwing
rocks at them so the Guardians of the
Galaxy get off to a pretty rough start
with these new people in this new world
now even though this planet looks a lot
like Earth it is very very far from
Earth and is actually ruled by the main
villain of this film and he is also the
person responsible for creating Rocket
Raccoon and this person is the high
evolutionary who they do show in this
trailer now a good majority of this film
is going to focus on the origin of
Rocket Raccoon and sort of ending his
story this is what James Gunn has
already said that he's set out to do
with Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
finishing Rocket's story so the next
scene we briefly see Star-Lord with some
upgraded headphones you can see he's
still listening to music as he always
does but he's got some upgraded gear and
then we hear man to say don't forget
where we came from and then we instantly
see a scene where a hand is reaching for
a baby raccoon this baby raccoon is
rocket and this situation was most like
the high evolutionary grabbing rocket to
experiment on him remember in the very
first Guardians of the Galaxy film when
rocket got drunk and he was yelling at
Drax and the rest of the Guardians he
said he didn't ask to get made he didn't
ask to get torn apart and get put back
together over and over again turned into
some little monster it's a very
important scene that you need to
remember no one's laughing at you he
thinks something stupid then he does
well I didn't ask to get made
I didn't have to be torn apart and put
back together over and over turn into
some
it's a little monster so this scene
right here directly ties into what
exactly is happening in Guardians 3.
rocket was made into who he is by the
person called the high evolutionary the
person that we see in this trailer as
the villain the high evolutionary was
just a normal person Herbert Edgar
Windham was born in England and he was a
student at Oxford in the 1930s who was
studying genetics and biology he created
a machine called the genetic accelerator
in which he attempted to evolve rats
eventually an inhuman who was an outcast
the geneticist fader gave him some
blueprints for cracking the genetic code
and from there he was finally able to
evolve his pet Dalmatian Dempsey into a
humanoid life form with the intelligence
of a chimpanzee however sadly poachers
came and they killed Dempsey this is
where he realized that his experiments
and himself would never really be safe
in the world so he took all of his
equipment and he moved to wundergore
Mountain now windigore Mountain has a
lot of serious implications not only in
Marvel Comics but also in the MCU as we
visited Wonder Gore Mountain and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
where the Scarlet Witch went to where
the dark hole was actually carved in
stone and some beans were there waiting
to worship her in the comics this is
where Herbert Edgar Wingham goes and he
develops a citadel of Science and he
continues his experiments and has many
more breakthroughs and he's essentially
able to turn his experiments into
half-human half animal beans with very
good intelligence and he would go on to
train his experiments in combat and he
called them the new men and they called
him the high evolutionary now the story
of the high evolutionary and the new man
on wundergore mountain is pretty complex
and very long but essentially what you
have to know for this trailer to
understand what's happening in Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 is that the new men
and the high evolutionary got attacked a
lot this led to the high evolutionary
building a protective armor suit the
suit that he's known for in the comics
and the suit that we see in this trailer
eventually he decided the world was too
much of a confining place for him so he
turned the Citadel of science into a
spaceship took all of his experiments
with him and he left and they eventually
landed on a planet and he created a
counter Earth a place just like Earth on
the opposite side of the Sun in which
him and his experiments called the
Newman inherited and inhabited and this
is what we are seeing in this trailer
this new planet that the Guardians go to
where it has humanoid animal life forms
where in the background you can see that
these homes in these streets and
everything looks just like Earth now it
seems like Rocket Raccoon escaped he was
experimented on torn apart put back
together again until he was finally able
to leave the clutches of the high
evolutionary and it seems like he had
been running from the high evolutionary
and possibly the new men for a very long
time but in this trailer we see him say
he's done running and right after he
says he's done running it shows us the
high evolutionary implying that they are
going to go after the high evolutionary
now when he says that in this scene we
can actually see in the background that
a lot of stuff is on fire it's in ruin
so it's safe to believe that he was
attacked him and the Guardians by
someone most likely the high
evolutionary and the people who work for
him who I also do believe could be Aisha
and The Sovereign who is responsible for
creating Adam Warlock who we do see in
this trailer which we'll talk about in
just a bit now in the next few scenes we
actually see Gamora now remember this is
not the same Gamora that the Guardians
knew sadly that Gamora is dead Thanos
did kill her to get the Soul Stone
however 2014 Gamora came into our
timeline and ran away but of course
since Star-Lord was in love with her and
the rest of the Guardians loved her as
well it seems like they all sought out
to find her and did find her now
obviously this Gamora does not have the
same relationship with the Guardians
that the other one did because she only
met the Guardians in Avengers end game
for like a very brief minute but she
knows that nebula is her sister and she
knows that the Guardians do care for her
so it looks like Gamora is going to try
and help them or possibly even seeking
out the high evolutionary four reasons
of her own but we do see her with the
guardians of the Galaxy we actually see
the Guardians in some type of prison and
it looks like Drax was actually shot in
this kind of hurt Gamora and mantis are
holding him up Star-Lord is in the
background it looks like they are trying
to escape now the high evolutionary
could have captured them and put them in
this prison and now they're trying to
escape we notice that we don't see
Rocket Raccoon in this so he could have
finally got to them or the Guardians
could have finally found him and he
could have captured them but is talking
to Rocket Raccoon because rocket is an
escaped experiment now there also is one
other component to this film like I just
mentioned the Sovereign and Adam Warlock
and the end of Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 2 in the post-credits scene we saw
that Aisha was creating a new life form
a new being and she specifically created
this Bean in its cocoon to kill the
Guardians of the Galaxy and she said she
will call him Adam this is Adam Warlock
who we do see in this trailer fighting
nebula or at least they are trying to
make us look like he is fighting nebula
now here's where I have a pretty big
Theory we know that from the events of
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 the
Sovereign is after the Guardians we know
that they are all about Evolution we
know that they actually don't birth
humans anymore they simply create them
the perfect example is Aisha creating
Adam Warlock with this cocoon and she
said it's a new Evolution for them The
Sovereign are all about perfection and
evolution that is exactly what the high
evolutionary is about as well so I do
think it's possible that the Sovereign
could actually be under the control of
the high evolutionary he is all about
Evolution he is all about perfecting
humanoid beings and that is exactly what
the Sovereign is about as well so it
just makes sense plus they mentioned in
the post-credits scene the council
wanted to meet with Aisha the high
evolutionary could be in charge of the
council we also have a scene in this
trailer where the high evolutionary is
observing a woman running now she's
running on something that kind of seems
to be like a cat wheel or a hamster
wheel this kind of shows that the high
evolutionary does treat his experiments
like animals however if we look at the
woman who is running she seems to be a
human now I do believe he created her so
I don't think she's an actual human but
this shows us that he is creating life
forms that aren't part animal he most
likely started by creating these half
animal half-human life forms but then
moved on to more human life forms like
The Sovereign perhaps so it is possible
he could have created The Sovereign this
would tie the two stories together the
post-credits scene from The Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 2 and Guardians of the
Galaxy 3. that's how Adam Warlock could
fit into the high evolutionary storyline
now also keep in mind that Adam Warlock
is going to be a villain but he's
probably going to turn good much like he
does in the comics in the comics he is
actually a Great Hero he's actually one
of my personal favorite heroes from the
comics so I'm assuming at some point in
time in this film most likely towards
the end he is going to somewhat become
good and eventually go on to become a
guardian of the galaxy himself but now
going back to the trailer I'm gonna say
from this part on it gets sad before the
trailer came out today we had a pretty
big feeling that some Guardians of the
Galaxy were going to die and then they
give us this scene where Rocket Raccoon
is lying on the floor and says we'll all
fly away together one last time into the
forever and beautiful sky now when he
says this we can notice that while he's
lying on the ground on the ground is
also pellets so I'm assuming the high
evolutionary captures rocket is super
mad at him for leaving and has a big
grudge against him and treats him just
like a raccoon and throws him in a cage
and puts pellets down there this is
somewhat of a torture for Rocket being
treated like a raccoon like an animal
and I'm assuming this scene is where a
guardian or Guardians find him however
we do get a scene not too long after
that of Star-Lord looking at somebody
and crying yelling no and it looks like
this person is hooked up to something as
we see some tubes there as well so
whoever this is is most likely being
experimented on by the high evolutionary
and the odds are it is probably rocket
however it could be any of the Guardians
we also have another shot of manta just
crying as well seemingly in a big big
Panic so sadly I think some of the
Guardians aren't going to make it out
alive I'm hoping they all do but I don't
think they are however let's not end on
a sad note there is something really
really happy that happens towards the
end of this trailer and that is rocket
embracing Lila Lila is Rocket's
girlfriend in the comics much like him
she is Genetically Enhanced but is an
otter however something truly cool is
that this is not actually the first
mention of Lila in the MCU she was
actually name dropped in the first
Guardians of the Galaxy when the
Guardians of the Galaxy are captured and
the Nova Corps are running criminal
backgrounds on them we can actually see
the associates of Rocket Raccoon are
Groot and Lyla this leads us to believe
especially with the way they Embrace
each other that they have already been
dating and in the comics they are the
love of each other's lives and it looks
like they were probably both captured by
the high evolutionary at some point in
time and were experimenting on and
Genetically Enhanced which is how
they're able to talk so if this is about
to be rocket raccoon's final moments I
am at least happy that he is going to be
with Lila once again one last time but
let's hope that rocket survives now in
the final details of this trailer we see
Star-Lord jump at somebody tackling them
out the window falling to the ground
this person is wearing all white and as
he jumps out the window you can see
another person in all white dead on the
floor and in the scene where Star-Lord
and Groot are shooting their way out of
something we can see other people
wearing white on the ground as well so
these people could be a new version of
the high evolutionaries Newman instead
of using half humanoid half animal
experiments he is now simply using
humanoid experiments to be his Newman
and his soldiers essentially and of
course we now have swole Groot and it
looks like he knows how to use his body
a little bit more as he's able to create
two other arms giving him four arms to
have a pretty tactical Advantage being
able to fire four weapons at once and
those are the important details that you
need to know about the Guardians of the
Galaxy of official trailer be sure to
let me know what you thought about this
in the comments down below and let us
know if you found any really cool Easter
eggs don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to the channel for more
breakdowns and other awesome news videos
related to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
you can always follow us on Instagram
and Twitter to keep up with live updates
and as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf